on va faire une interview tir aux
pigeons
allons-y alors facile pour commencer
françois hollande
l'incapable du mieux oui c'est pas mal
nicolas sarkozy le très capable du pire
marine le pen notre copine marine le pen
la honte des enfants de vedettes assez
bon la honte des fix ii voilà
je suis désolé frédéric beigbeder mais
ça va recommencer recouche
parcours d'un collabo à saint germain
des prés voilà après tu commencé comme
ça de la cac le mec pendant la guerre il
l'aurait dénoncé anne franck tu vois
mais après l'avoir niké kom faut dire
comme la décharge de frédéric que ce
grand parents ont caché des juifs un
travail oui m'enfin c'est pas
héréditaire le kunar
eric naulleau la bave du crapaud te
houle la laurence ferrari laurence
ferrari le charme torride de la
bourgeoisie de province
auront été
le bon camarade moins long ces propos ce
que je travaille avec lui tu sais bien
ils me payent pas c'est là où catherine
barma et forte jusque là c'est c'est
très rare de rencontrer quelqu'un
d'aussi solides aussi fiable si droit
dans ce milieu doria tillier la miss
météo de canal
soit belle et ouvre la
dynamique si la ja il faut pas me
chercher
je dirais l'amputer du beau du chic et
du fin mais je ne me moque jamais des
handicapés
alessandra sublet
alexandra sublet il y avait un petit
malaise un derrière l'argent on sent que
ça cartonne quand même hanouna vous avez
dit alessandra sublet l'éclat de rire
qui pardonne tout oui sophia aram
l'absence de rire qui ne pardonne pas
archi pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu